so what we have are three different
pictures of substances undergoing some
type of change and what we're going to
focus on in this video is classifying
things as either being physical changes
or chemical changes and you might have
already thought about this or seen this
in a previous science class but when we
talk about a physical change we're
talking about where there could be a
change in properties but we're not
having a change in the actual
composition of what we're talking about
while in a chemical change you actually
do have a change in composition how the
different constituent atoms and elements
match up or connect or bond to each
other might be different so my first
question to you is pause this video and
we have some ice melting here we have
some propane combusting or burning here
and we have some iron rusting here and I
want you to think about which of these
are physical changes and which of these
are chemical changes and
why all right now let's first think
about about this water this ice melting
and if we wanted to write it in fancy
chemical language or chemistry language
we could write this as H2O going from
its solid form to H2O going into its
liquid form now we don't have a change
in composition in either State whether
you're looking at this liquid water here
or whether you're looking at the solid
water there you'll see a bunch of water
molecules each oxy is still bonded to
two hydrogens and so you're not having a
change in composition and so this over
here is a physical physical change and
if we kept heating that water up and it
started to vaporize that would also be a
physical change whereas it turns into
water vapor you have your intermolecular
forces being overcome but the calent
bonds between the oxygens and the
hydrogens those aren't breaking or
forming in some way so once again when
you you go from Ice to water physical
change from water to Vapor or you could
say from liquid to gas that is also
going to be a physical change one
general rule of thumb when you think
about what's going on on a microscopic
level and this is a general rule of
thumb it doesn't always apply and we'll
think about an edge case in a little bit
is when you're overcoming intermolecular
forces that tends to be a physical
change but if you have chemical bonds
forming or breaking that would be a
chemical change
now let's think about what's going on
here with the propane if you were to
write the chemical reaction here it
would be propane C3 h8 in gas form it
needs oxygen to combust so for every
mole of propane we have five moles of
molecular oxygen in gas form and then
when it combusts you're going to produce
three for every one mole of propane and
5 moles of molecular oxygen you're going
to produce three moles of carbon diox
oxide gas and four moles of water in
vapor form as well and so what you
actually have is the bonds in those
molecules are actually breaking and then
reforming so you don't just have
physical change going on here you have
chemical change chemical change one way
to think about it you had protan propane
here before C3 h8 after the reaction you
no longer have the propane here what you
see as fire which is fascinating this is
just very hot gas and that very hot air
that you're seeing and there's going to
be some carbon dioxide in there and
there's going to be some water vapor in
there the reason why it's getting so hot
is because this releases a lot of energy
now let's think about what's going on
here with this iron if I were to write
this as a chemical reaction for every
four moles of iron in solid form plus
three moles of molecular oxygen
in gas form and that would just be the
ambient oxygen around this iron it is
going to produce 2 mol of iron
oxide as a solid and that's what you see
there in the orange that is the iron
oxide so notice this reaction is forming
new ionic bonds in that Ferris oxide and
to undergo the reaction we had to break
the metallic bonds of the solid iron and
the Cove valent bonds in the molecular
oxygen so anytime we are breaking and
making these chemical bonds we have a
chemical change